joining us now to break down how the
coronavirus might affect the election
and the presidency is CBS News senior
political analyst John Dickerson he
joins us from his home here in New York
John good morning as always exactly the
person I want to talk to at a moment
like this every election is gonna be a
contest between candidates this election
is also a test of democracy itself some
states want to vote by mail the
president opposes that idea as we debate
how to do campaign 2020 and how to vote
what are some of the democratic
principles we should all bear in mind
well it's good to be with you Tony as
always even in this distant way you know
one of the things that's striking in the
eds piece today is that that number of
the majority the country that now
believes in mail-in ballots that's up
from 32 percent in 2018 so the country
is moving there and if dr. Anthony found
she is right and it's going to be a bad
fall then what this is at the very
beginning is a test of Kogut 19
responses by public officials
and I think we just we just lost John
Dickerson